amici fantastici sono con jean stiamo
per registrare jump forze che è uno dei
giochi più fighi personalmente che ho
visto all'e3 di los angeles almeno che
mi ha colpito come co co me mi ha
colpito la bibla geno con con i pulmini
colori bloccai ok
oggi volevo provare visto che un gioco
un picchiaduro e marino lo giochiamo in
teoria in due perché i picchiaduro si
giocano in due però non ci sia sullo
script ma se non sarebbe un po una noia
però se è come in sé in sei a todi al
sole simili non dovrebbero esserci
vediamo infilando un cubo nel bene
questo è trans da una vita che non lo
vedevo in un gioco da budokai tenkaichi
tra effettivamente trunks ma è
abbastanza da costante sino a me sono io
che non sono una costante tutti i giochi
cosa sta facendo fa tutto lui tu non ti
preoccupare sono giochetti appresi che
si giocano da soli
va bene facciamolo ti prego a dalla
donna maschio scegli tu da lì poi
andiamo allora dobbiamo decidere se
volevo fare ridicolo a schifo e vogliamo
che la ridicola schifo rara violent
narrativo attimo di tipo i ceri poi ci
ha più stir e credo sia più stile dra no
semplicemente bianconero o più asiatico
credo che facciamo asiatico va bene a
921 gianni un po che è un po più avuto
alla l'acconciatura acconciatura
facciamola di capelli alla giorgio come
parla così ci sono gli afro mamma mia
i punteruoli bellis ti apro poi pelato
pelato non ho però ovviamente nel senso
cioè pelati sì sì ma è ovvio che c'è
sempre penato è la cosa che ti costa di
meno livello di poligoni puoi fare così
e facevo immediato lega pro c'è uno
megafono come fa uno bianco bianchissimo
mai visto un avro bianco no ma neanche
rosso prova però se con un pò troppo
caldo già già così non è l'attaccatura
dei capelli che comincia tipo qua dietro
mamma mia ragazza e khrin gissi ma va
bene dai o ciccione basso sì e credo
anche io lasciamoci cene bassissimo ma
non puoi divertirti troppo
che fastidio colore della pelle lo
facciamo comunque ridere lo facciamo una
meccano se dai vai di verde ma male è
verissimo cos'è imbarazzantissimo
veramente perdita per ok sopracciglia ma
doc queste queste qui con il full minino
non sono male anche fulmini
effettivamente famiglia che cose troppo
serio dai sopracciglioni dice bianchi
sembra più prezzi abbiano almeno la
croma e la cromatura dei peli sia negli
occhi così che combatte senza guardare
combat occhi chiusi per combatterla
scatta il terzo il terzo ed un secondo
secondo che sembra di quelle immagini
ente ai gay che preso atto rimane sempre
gri non vede pupille tanto sono chiuse
però dentro sociale gli occhiali occhi
neri della golf praticamente la pupilla
ad essa si siano senza delivery naso
voglio marzo spazio merriman esatto
bocca e mandibola bello così così col
boccone caratteristica 1 ai tatuaggi
tipo
mamma mia il trucco il così di naruto di
boa
questa è veramente ma ancora non lo so
pur clown ama così mi sono quindi hisoka
di hunter hunter
questo è il post madonna figo dai
diamogli un tocco di figaggine guidare
questo sì dai
va bene ha poi posizionarlo va bene ma
sì così va bene fa un fa molto kiss
sembra che abbia un telefono li è pronto
motivo si è caratteristica 2 mentre
mercoledì nelle di sasuke ok quel
puntino sul naso per un perfetto che è
bello voce rilasciate da mesi si 1
chiamiamo nei blue apple tipo è a esatto
e bo
esatto perché confermano serie mi è
piaciuto tantissimo questa creazione di
anatra va bene tutto quello che ci
abbattere la giocherà mai no ma ora che
io nei giochi in cui è presente la
creazione personaggi una delle cose che
mi diverte di più si perché lo fai tutto
strano ma anche se lo fai bene se lo fai
strano
gli dico che in mass effect aveva creato
il luogo più brutto dell'universo gli
avevo fatto con il gioco disabilitabili
del 2006 e guarda tipo di dati personali
erano fortissimi se ti di busta vi lui
niente si è svegliato ma in realtà è
dormiente sempre come sempre il suo
quirk la ricostruzione è stata
completata con successo più o meno
tranquilla dal pm o meno a dobbiamo
combattere contro friggere il povero ok
si tipo il cavaliere di virgo dei
cavalieri dello zodiaco agli occhi
chiusi perché si riaprì succede un
bordello
in questo momento sono uno che può
menare tutti ma mi hanno svegliato dal
dal mio sonno ma anche tra chi sta messo
sto il cubo di rubik esser act nel petto
e quello che ho dato potere come mi ha
dato la fascia sparatutto si è forte e
mubarak e l'amalgama che la gente lo
guarda e bobo
vai a battere un po grazie dove doppiata
dalla è una tipa questa questa parola
signora un'anziana signora e lo doppia
data da sempre comunque sempre ma che
posto di relax ma piazza gae aulenti è
vero quanto in piazza che volenti sta
roba
c'è anche il bar facevo di musica disco
di sotto di dilatare il re caio che sia
un po evolute lo sciatore caio che ha
detto ho firmato l'impresa edile cosa
sto vedendo amy scappato come le altre
20mila volte sono goku sasuke naruto tu
sei c'è veramente ti è uscito questo che
naruto sasuke zoro e sanji è pronto
no allora con redditi careghi le energie
saluti ai premuto puoi fare gli attacchi
speciali con kuadra poi con tipo con r1
mi corre addosso sono ri cordo se no se
ho capito bene con delle due cambi
personaggio questo è quello che ho
capito che tanto sembra veramente
cazzuta la grafica g star ofono che è
tutto talmente veloci come faccio a
diventare io non so cosa starà super
sayan traguardo così come si diventa
soggetto super sayan mannaia anche atene
bob game mai giocato fai cose non me la
cavo male con
galan ea no certo il mio futuro
materasso che mi ha realizzato un mio
addio schivate il 1000 falchi non ti
conviene scambiare personaggio è perché
non sta benissimo sasco non sta
benissimo
si vede che almeno di mettere pare che
cosa è stato controllato che se non
capiremo niente abbia preso zero ma ed
ora non ho mai messe già morto ma mai si
credo si avvita generale di tanti non
c'è la vita solo 21 mila falchi
credo che ci sia un po frutta come
scelta non capivo sta roba dice che
tutti hanno cioè hai una vita
comunitaria di tutto diventa una scelta
è un signor a giugno san g die che
c'entro io ai un ambito
porco schifo non si fa parare tra
l'altro non si può parlare credo credo è
certo ma che l'ha presa molto elastico
potente
mammamia cos'è sta roba
penso a vicenza pagina e avvolgente e
così compie classe soprattutto ok
vai naruto naruto sasuke contro una
ruota che faremo in un cane stereo sfera
ma cosa è successo non ho capito a chi
sta lanciando letterio sfere maria sfera
rosa e jolie kadima
ma se come credo sia di totale generale
c'è tutti hanno la stessa vita io sì e
mi sei anni ucciso studi rai
io ho fatto io smetto ho smesso di le
generose con lo sci pudente tutta sta
roba non so cosa sia mamma mia
malvaglia fina rai si decidono oggi su
cristo
io mi sono parato non so quanto è
servito ti ho fatto niente e ho fatto un
buffetto sulla guancia di dato non si
vede perché la mia webcam sta coprendo
pensi che devi fare è bravo a donna che
ama le misero a perché la camera in cui
mi sono teletrasportato dietro di te è
finito proprio quella roba vi è
veramente dio stammi lontano paura cosa
cosa sto facendo ma siamo sul punto
messian dopo cosa sta succedendo mi o
madonna in fascisti ma proprio a genchi
dopo nulla la gt dama madonna e
cameraman è veramente basta non sta
riuscendo a fare perciò prossimi ed
operato con un ora fare una cosa e non
sono riuscito a fare prova fare molto
speciale va bene gol a faceva mai non
l'ha mai fatta già provato per giorno
questo era già force molto figo molto
carino è bello quando ti scontri con gli
stessi personaggi non si capisce una
madre che però va beh l'importante è
partecipare i ragazzi che vi sia
piaciuto anche ho visto subito
descrizione e noi ci vediamo a un
prossimo video sia
[Musica]
no